نمسکر پہلے اور دوسرے فیز میں ووٹنگ بہت کم ہوئی
ہندو باہول علاقوں کے پولنگ بوتھوں پر
کم ہوتی لائنوں نے صاف سنکھے دیا ہے
کہ جنتا اب جملوں سے اوب چکی ہے
دونوں چرنوں میں حالت خستہ ہے
اور اسے مودی کی بھاشا سے بڑی آسانی سے سمجھا جا سکتا ہے
دوستو جو نریندر مودی کل تک چار سو کا گانا گاتے تھے
وہ اب دو سو بہتر کی بات کرنے لگے ہیں
کہتے ہیں کہ سرکار بنانے کے لیے دو سو بہتر سیٹیں چاہیے
اور بی جے پی کو چھوڑ کر کوئی دوسری پارٹی
دو سو بہتر سیٹوں پر چنابی نہیں لڑ رہا ہے
اب اس بات پر بھی مودی جی جھوٹ بولتے ہی پکڑے گئے
کیونکہ اب تک کانگریس نے تین سو
سولہ سیٹوں پر اپنے امیدوار گوشت کر دیے
ایک یہ ہیں بھائی صاحب
ان کو سمجھ میں ہی نہیں آرہا ہے
کہ مودی کو چار سو سیٹیں دینی ہیں
یا بغل والے ٹینٹ ہاؤس سے چار ہزار سیٹیں آرڈر کرنی ہیں
ہم تو چاہتے ہیں کہ پورے بیہار میں چالیس سیٹ لڑنا ہے
چالیسوں سیٹ جیت جائیں
اور دیس بھر میں تو ہم چاہتے ہیں کہ چار ہزار سے
چار ہزار سے مودی کی بوکھلاہٹ
اور چناب آیوں کے کام کرنے کے طریقے کو اگر آپ
آپس میں ملا کر دیکھیں گے
تو شک کی سوئی
بے معنی کی طرف گھوم جاتی ہے
دوستو بھارت کے چناوی اتحاس میں پہلی بار ایسا ہوا ہے
جب چناویوں نے دس دن بعد دس دن بعد ووٹنگ پرسنٹیج
بدل دیا ہو یا پھر فائنل ڈیٹا کہہ کر ریلیز کر دیا ہو
ویسے تو دو تین دن میں الیکشن
کمیشن فائنل ڈیٹا دے دیتا ہے
چوبیس گھنٹے سے زیادہ کا وقت لگتا ہی نہیں ہے
اب تک اتحاس میں
کبھی بھی دو سے تین دن سے زیادہ کا دن نہیں لگا
اس سے زیادہ سمے نہیں لگا
لیکن اس بار دس دن بعد ووٹنگ پرتیشت میں
پانچ پرتیشت بڑوتری کرکے فائنل ڈیٹا اپلوڈ کیا گیا ہے
یہ پرتیشر یہ ووٹ پرتیشر کیسے بڑھے
اس کی کوئی جانکاری الیکشن کمیشن نے ابھی تک نہیں دی ہے
بہت سارے دلوں نے آواز بھی اٹھائی
لوگوں نے شنکا بھی ظاہر کی
لیکن اب تک جب میں آپ کے سامنے یہ ویڈیو بنا رہی ہوں
دوستوں تب تک
الیکشن کمیشن نے اپنی طرف سے کچھ بھی سپشش نہیں بتایا ہے
کیا یہ من مانی ہے
یا پھر یہ پھر کچھ اور ہے
دال میں کچھ تو کالا ہے
پانچ پرتیشر ووٹ آخر کس کے بڑھ گئے
کس کی طرف کے بڑھ گئے
اتنی دیر بعد ڈاٹا کیوں بدل دیا گیا
یا پھر اپلوڈ کیوں کیا گیا اتنی دیر بعد
لیکن کوئی جواب نہیں ہے
سا دارن بھاشا میں اسے دھورتتا کہا جاتا ہے
چناب آیوق کا ویوار رہسمای ہے
کیونکہ متدان کے دن نو بجے
گیارہ بجے ایک بجے
تین بجے پانچ بجے سات بجے تک کا ووٹنگ اپڈیٹ آتا ہے
عام طور پر اگلے دن اس ووٹنگ پرتیشت میں
کچھ تین چار پرتیشت کا ڈاٹا بڑھتا ہے
جو فائنل ڈیٹا ہوتا ہے
اس بار اگلے دن تو ہمیشہ کی طرح
ووٹنگ پرتیشر بڑھ کر آیا ہی
دس دن کے بعد
ایک بار اور ووٹنگ پرتیشر اور بڑھا کر دکھا دیا گیا
انیس اپریل کو متدان ہوا
اس میں گیارہ دن بعد چھ دشمنا زیرو
سات پروتشت کی بڑھوتڑی ہوگئی
چھبیس اپریل کو جو ووٹنگ ہوئی
اس میں چار دن کے بعد پانچ دشمنا سات
پانچ پروتشت کی بڑھوتڑی ہوگئی
اب اتنے دن بعد یہ کیسے ہو گیا
کون سا چمکدار ہو گیا
کیوں ہو گیا اس کا کوئی جواب نہیں ہے
جیسے یہ طعنہ شاہی سسٹم میں ہوتا ہے نا
بالکل ویسے ہی ہو گیا ہے
پچھلے پینتیس سال سے میں چناؤ دیکھ رہا ہوں
لکھ رہا ہوں حصہ بھی لیا ہے
لیکن اس بار جو ہوا ویسا کبھی نہیں دیکھا
پہلے چناب والے دن شام کو الیکشن کمیشن بتاتا تھا
اتنا مردار ہوا
اگلے دن دوپہر تک اس میں ہمیشہ ریویژن ہوتا تھا
دو پرسنٹ چار پرسنٹ بڑھتا تھا
لیکن اگلے دن زیادہ سے زیادہ دوپہر
کبھی کبھار اگلے دن شام تک
چوبیس گھنٹے کے اندر الیکشن کمیشن آپ کو
فائنل آنکھڑا دے دیتا تھا
کس کانسٹیٹیونسی نے کتنے ووٹر
کتنے ووٹر نے ووٹ دیا
محلہ پروش ہر سیگمنٹ پر
اس بار تین بدلات ہیں
پہلا الیکشن کمیشن نے ایک ایپ بنا دیا
اس ایپ میں ڈیٹا آ رہا تھا
کانسٹیٹیونسی وائز آ رہا تھا
لیکن بدلتا گیا
بدلتا گیا
ایک دن نہیں دو دن نہیں تین چوتھے دن تک بدلتا گیا
نمبر دو چوتھے دن کے آخر پہ بھی الیکشن
کمیشن نے فائنل آکڑا ریلیز نہیں کیا
گیارہ دن بعد انیس تاریخ کا آکڑا
تیس تاریخ کو جا کے ریلیز کیا
اور تیسرا جب ریلیز بھی کیا
تب بھی یہ نہیں بتایا کہ
بارہ لاکھ تین انتالیس ہزار دو سو چھپن ہو گئے
نہیں یہ کہا
چھپن دشملہ پانچ شنے پتیشت
فرق کیا ہے پتیشت کے آکڑا جب لاکھوں کی سنکھیاں ہو
تو اس میں دو سو پانچ سو ہزار کا ہے
پھر تو آرام سے ہو سکتا ہے
پتیشت کے حساب سے
چناؤ وائیو ایسے کانڈ پہلے بھی کر چکا ہے
دو ہزار انیس میں
ڈالے گئے ووٹ سے زیادہ ووٹ
ایویم سے گنتی کے دوران نکلے تھے
اس بار چناؤ وائیو نے ڈیٹا ہی نہیں دیا ہے
کس جگہ پر کتنے لوگوں نے ووٹ کیا
صرف پرتیشر بتایا ہے
وہ بھی دس دن کے بعد
وہ بھی بڑھا کر
دوسری سب سے بڑی بات غور کرنے والی یہ ہے دوستوں
کہ ایک طرف
پہلے دو چنوں میں بی جے پی کی حالت بہت پتلی ہوئی
اتنی پتلی ہوئی کہ مودی بوکھلا گئے
کہنے لگی کہ کانگریس منگل سوتر چھین لے گی
اگر آپ کے دو گھر ہوں گے تو ایک گھر کانگریس چھین لے گی
یہاں تک کہ انہوں نے یہ بھی کہہ دیا
کہ اگر آپ کے پاس دو بھینسیں ہوں گی
تو ایک بھینس کانگریس
آپ سے چھین کر کے مسلمانوں کو دے دے گی
پہلے تو ہندو خطرے میں ہیں
یہ کہہ کر مسلمانوں سے ڈراتے تھے
اب کی بار مودی نے ہندوؤں کے لیے
خطرے کا لیول تھوڑا اور بڑھا دیا ہے
اب ہندوؤں کی بھینسوں کو بھی نہیں چھوڑا ہے
ان کو بھی مسلمانوں سے خطرہ ہے
بھئی اپنی بھینس بچانی ہو
بکری بچانی ہو
مرغا مرغی بچانا ہو تو مودی کو ووٹ دے دیجیے
صاف طور پر یہی چل رہا ہے
مودی دیش کے ہر ورگ کو ڈرا کر ووٹ مانگ رہے ہیں
دو چرنوں نے مودی کا یہ حال کر دیا ہے
تیسرا اور چوتھا چرن بھی ایسا ہی رہا
ڈرانے کے بعد بھئی دھمکانے کا بھی راونڈ شروع ہو سکتا ہے
راحیل گاندھی نے پردھان منتری کے اول جلول
اور اس طرح کی برتاؤ سے اوپر
مودی کی بہکی بہتی باتوں سے اوپر ایکس پر کیا لکھا ہے
وہ آپ کو سننا چاہیے
راحیل گاندھی نے لکھا ہے
ایک ہٹاش نراش اور ہارے ہوئے پردھان منتری کی باتیں سنیے
کانگریس آپ کے گھر کا کمرہ چھین لے گی
کانگریس آپ کے گلے کا منگل سوتر چھین لے گی
کانگریس صاحب کی بھینس چھین لے گی
نریندر مودی ایسی بہکی
بہکی اور جھوٹی باتیں صرف اس لیے کر رہے ہیں
کیونکہ کانگریس ان کی تین سو میں سے
ڈیڑھ سو سے زیادہ سیٹیں چھین کر سرکار بنا رہی ہے
اس ڈر میں مودی پردھان منتری کی
گرماں کو بھول کر جھوٹ کی مشین بن گئے ہیں
انڈیا کی سرکار جنتا سے لے گی نہیں بلکہ انہیں دے گی
اتنا ہی پیسہ دے گی
جتنا مودی نے اپنے ارب پتی مترو پر لٹایا ہے
ہماری سرکار اڈانیوں کی نہیں ہندوستانیوں کی
ہوگی منگل
سوتر اور بھینس چھن جانے کے ڈر سے گلگوٹیا یونیورسٹی کے
برین واش بچے
کانگریس کاریلے کے سامنے پردرشن کرنے کے لیے پہنچ گئے
اب جب ان سے پوچھا گیا کہ بھیا بھارت کے برین واش بھوش
آپ یہ پردرشن کیوں کر رہے ہیں
تو گلگوٹیا کے بچے یہ بتا ہی نہیں پائے
کہ وہ پردرشن کرنے کے لیے آئے کیوں ہیں
برین واش بچوں کو دیکھ کر لگا
کہ مودی کے روڈ شو اور ریلیوں میں مودی
مودی کا نعرہ لگانے کا ٹھیکہ
ایسے ہی بچوں کو دیا جاتا ہوگا کیا
ریلیوں میں بھیڑ بھی گلگوٹیا والے ہی سپلائی کرتے ہیں کیا
اس بات کو اب پوچھا جانا چاہیے
یہ دیکھا جانا چاہیے کہ اسکول
کالج اور پرائیویٹ یونیورسٹیوں میں کیا ایسے ہی برین واش
بم بنائے جا رہے ہیں
خیر دیش کے ماں باپوں
جاگ جائیے آپ نے پائی
پائی جوڑ کر اپنے بچوں کو پڑھنے کے لیے بھیجا ہے
گلگوٹیاں والے
انہیں تو انہیں کرایہ کا کارکردہ بنا دیا ہے
جاگیے جن نیتاؤں کے لیے آپ کے بچوں کو برین
واشڈ کر کے ایک فوج میں بدل دیا گیا ہے
اس پارٹی کے نیتاؤں کے بچے بی
سی سی آئی میں موج کر رہے ہیں
آنکھیں کھولیے
کل کو کوئی یہ نہ کہے پچیس سال بعد
پچاس سال بعد آج کے وقت کو جب لوگ یاد کریں گے
تو آنے والی پیڑیاں ہم سے ایک سوال پوچھیں گی
کہ جب ان دیش کے وش ودیالیوں کو برباد کیا جا رہا تھا
وہاں گوبر پر ریسرچ
کرایا جا رہا تھا
گوشالہ کھولی جا رہی تھی
پرائیویٹائز کیا جا رہا تھا
فیس مہنگی کی جا رہی تھی
اپائنمنٹ گھٹیا لوگوں کے کیے جا رہے تھے
جن کا اے پی آئی بہت کم ہے
اور کیڈر کا بھرتی ہو رہی تھی
آر ایس ایس کے ایک وچاردھارا کے لوگ وہاں بھرے جا رہے تھے
تب تم کیا کر رہے تھے
کیونکہ باقی زمانہ تو پتہ ہی نہیں تھا
وہ تو کیمپس میں تھا نہیں نا
گھروں میں بیٹھے ریٹائرڈ انکلوں سے لے کر سکول کالج تک
سکول کالج سے لے کر کمپنیوں کے امپلائز تک
سب کو پہلے شکنجہ ان پر کسا گیا
پھر ان کو شکنجے میں لیا گیا
آج کے تارک میں
بھارت میں کسی بھی پرائیویٹ کمپنی میں کام کرنے والا وقت
بی جے پی کی خراب نیتیوں کے بارے میں
کھل کر سوشل میڈیا سائیڈ پر لکھ ہی نہیں سکتا
یہ اے چار پالیسی بنا دی گئی ہے
مودی کی تعریف سے
نو پرابلم کوئی پرابلم نہیں ہے
لیکن کریٹیشن سے نوکریاں چلی جاتی ہیں
چلیے چلتے ہیں نمسکر